[Music]
you've said the goal of philosophy
is to thrust us into absent emergencies
in order to disrupt the ongoing return
to order
being imposed on us could you tell me
what that means and why it's so
significant
i think we find ourselves now in a
condition
where not the only but the greatest in
other words the biggest
emergency is the absence for emergency
in other words
those emergencies that we do not take
seriously into
we do not we do not tackle we do not
confront
uh for example let's say right now let's
say
the pandemic we're living now uh the
pandemic it's an emergency now there's
no doubt about it but
five months ago well seven months ago
it was an absence emergency in other
words we were warm
for the past decades by mike davis by
so many scientists by the world health
organization that
pandemic could could arrive could take
place
uh and not not much has been done
against that
another example even a better example i
think
is climate change let's say air
pollution
that's an absence emergency in other
words it's the greatest emergency
because we're not confronted
seven million people die every year of
problems related to to the lungs
due to the pollution there is and we
have not confronted
that so um the greatest emergency has
become
the absence of emergency those
emergencies that we do not seriously
take into consideration
and when we do take them um when we do
confront them
often it's a little bit too late and so
i think it's very important to think
well what what's the difference between
how do we how can i explain the
difference between
uh a state of emergency something that
kash meet and
gamble and explain and the condition in
which we are now um i think a good way
to
to point the difference is to think of
the difference between george bush
presidency
and donald trump if you remember donald
uh george bush
you know he actually put into effect the
state of emergency state of deception
and uh and again explain how he was
using that in
extra legal ways in order to to change
the laws and everything
so that would be what bush did but 20
years later
actually a little bit a little bit more
than that we find ourselves with a
different president for whom instead
what characterized him is the absence of
emergency uh trump is known and he's not
the only one unfortunately
for not taking emergencies into
consideration for example uh even even
the coronavirus he downplayed that for a
very long time
uh and before that he did not recognize
any uh
climate change so he really incarnates
he really takes it
inside this this whole idea of an
absence of emergency
do you think the responsibility lies
collectively since 9 11 basically since
the beginning of the century
we have experienced an intensification
of measures of control so basically
nothing really changed after 9 11.
nothing really changed
also after the 2008 2009 financial
crisis
and i'm a little bit afraid that uh i
hope it will change but
things might not change too much either
after this emergency
living now i think this uh these
emergencies all these
emergencies have in other words have
intensified even more
uh the role of that finance played in
liberal finance play
that military control played uh and also
even from a cultural point of view
there has been a stronger reduction okay
uh of uh of of the possibilities we have
of freedom now
example well let's see how we are now
unfortunately many of us are are
manipulated
maybe a small percent of us but a lot of
us are manipulated through
uh social media when we go to elections
or when we try to find
good information or when we try to uh so
i have a feeling that
now there is an intensification the fact
that google has so much power
well this is a problem as far as our
freedom is concerned
this is what i try to to explain
in my in my new book which is called
being at large
well is it possible to be at large today
uh i think that uh someone for
you know in the 60s and 70s some of her
parents they could actually go through
europe at
large nobody would really know where you
were you might be on a train somewhere
um now it's very difficult to be at
large
it's uh it's very difficult to escape in
some way
uh although one might feel free right
but we are free within certain uh
specific
and very frame what i like to call a
global frame order
and and there has been a reaction to
that both uh philosophically
a very conservative reaction to that and
also there has been a very progressive
reaction to that
which uh i think this is this is very
clear in um
what we can see in both new realism
philosophy
the so-called ooo ontology and also all
the people who have been trying to
discredit any sort of postmodern views
uh that instead sustain our concern of
this problem
how helpful is freedom if we are going
to tackle something like climate change
first thing we have to do is probably
to recognize that there is a problem
with freedom i think
that's the first point because otherwise
it seems that
uh oh just the way we we react well no
there's actually a problem with freedom
uh there's a problem of the freedoms we
have and the limits we can
we can through back uh how do we do this
well i think that
the idea of i what i try to explain in
my research is that
but we have to find ways not to rescue
us
from emergencies but rather to rescue us
into emergencies in other words uh there
is a sort of
connotation of salvation here that
perhaps this is particularly clear in
art art
i think that very you see
environmentalists artists for example
but you know they might show you
glaciers or some environmental concerns
but they're really they're really trying
to to trust to push us
into these emergencies i think that's
one way of being free
to to to recall for example that
for example i think philosophically i
think it's important today to
to remind everyone that modernism is
what's not it's not a was not a movement
to
to to create chaos um i think stanley
fish
which has been hosted in this festival i
think he explained very clearly uh
in several his papers how past modernism
did not win chaos past modern ninja
warner of the problem of not having any
chaos at all in other words of having
one single truth or to continue to use
rationality
as a sort of universal paradigm to which
we can impose
our values upon others so the idea of of
being
in some way resistance to to this
rationality
i think it's very important because
unfortunately i think
um there's a whole movement called the
intellectual dark web
uh people like peterson and sam harris
and
another that well there is a return a
return to order
there uh what in uh they used to call in
france after the first world war
there were two a lord the sort of idea
that we have to return to order because
of
everything possible modernism did the
problem is that this return to order
is really this this lack of emergency in
other words making sure that
um well the refugee crisis is not
considered a terrible emergency as it is
or even that
even the climate change is not so
important as it is
so the idea here is to how do we how do
we oppose
um this return to order this global
frame return to order
well i think that on the one hand we
have to try to recall all what
of modern philosophers from your darts
from mauman
uh sometimes they fish and so many
others uh recall that well the idea here
is to
to make sure that make sure that
philosophy
philosophy is a very good can be a very
good servant of politics
but it's a very bad master of politics
and this is a distinction that i did not
do but which avoided it
and i think the idea also returning to
all just like richard royety who by the
way
in 1997 uh predicted the rights of trump
the democratic party continued to behave
the way it did and the way it does now
so i think there is we still have a lot
to learn uh from there and the fact that
we return
in some way to this modernity
uh where that in some way justified also
colonialism
i think it's an alarming feature why is
it important that we be thrust into
those emergencies why does it matter to
be
responding to them again i think that
the greatest emergencies we have are the
ones we do not confront
so um if those are for example trump
represents
it's a paradigmatic example here he
represents or
also bolsonaro that said that the
criminal bias was not an emergency for a
very long time
uh actually i think they're they even
probably now uh downplaying it
as i speak i hope not but uh and i think
that that's the biggest emergency we
have those that
still today uh you know do not consider
these greatest emergencies we have
um so that's the real the first problem
we have
uh why well because um let's let's think
of this way
what are what are warnings warnings are
really signs from the future they're
basically
indications we have that you know you
can you can
accept them or not but there are signs
that in some way are not there to
predict the future but
they warn us in other words they work or
they function as a sort of pressure
you know that we do not you know in such
a way that emergencies do not actually
take place
and i have a feeling that warnings are
not taken very seriously i mean
the pandemic has they warned us for a
very long time about the pandemic
and for a very long time it has not it
has not taken seriously
was not taken seriously uh and
there's a problem here of how how come
how come the question is well
how come we don't listen to warnings
this is the question i think
well i think one of the reasons we do
not listen to warnings is because of
this frame order that i mentioned before
and also because well
also because you know given social media
uh tremendous power and and in the
internet in general
uh and therefore the the lack of
authority now
established newspapers established
experts established
universities in other words those
traditional vectors of authority we
always
funded our beliefs on which of course
were not ultimate truth but they had
some sort of
authority we considered you know
i think the new york times has more
authority than an anonymous blogger
somewhere on the web
so um the problem here is that
they lost that authority and it's and
today
you have to actually make an effort in
order to to find the truth
also because and this is something that
something else i think it's very
important is
well you know bruno latour his
last last book translated into english
down to earth
he explains that facts truths
do not they don't work on their own uh
scientists can come and explain to us
right now the process through which
ice is melting but that's not enough for
us to make to do something about it in
order to
for as a collective society to
understand it we need
many other factors of authority for
example public debates
or or other scientists who also claim
other politicians who also agree upon it
so facts alone don't work this is why i
think that
what do you mean what you said before
why do we need to be pushed into this
emergency as well because
unfortunately truth alone does not work
this is why i think it's a good example
here is um
how come greta timber which i admire
like everybody
i think does how come her message works
better than so many scientists
well her message works better than so
many scientists because her emergency
has
more it's more intense than the message
that perhaps a scientist managed to get
through
well there is an intensity there of
truth okay
that we need in order to in order to
react to this absence of emergencies
brilliant well thank you very much for
more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to the institute of art
and ideas
at iai tv